[Musique]
notre séance ce soir Nicolas Duvernois
et Diane Bérard vous pouvez prendre le
temps de respirer Diane qui est
d'arriver comme un cheveu
bonsoir à vous deux
alors bon franchement arrivé pour nous
parler de ce que vous pensez de cette
offre qui a été déposée par le
gouvernement fédéral aujourd'hui on nous
dit 46 milliards de dollars d'argent
neuf à peu près mais quand on compare ça
à ce que les provinces demandaient
c'était 28 milliards par année sur 10
ans il y a un énorme écart est-ce que ça
vous surprend qu'il y a un si grand
écart entre les deux positions pour
vraiment j'ai écouté avec attention la
conférence de César et je suis pas
surprise d'ailleurs il y a plusieurs
premiers ministres qui ont mentionné que
l'argent n'allait pas tout régler ils
ont parlé d'un système de santé qui
datait des années
50-60-70 donc un système de santé qui
était désuet donc je suis pas surprise
ils ont demandé beaucoup mais
satanait-il à avoir autant pas
nécessairement et j'ai pas senti
chez eux non plus c'était très calme
personne qui a déchiré sa chemise
c'était vraiment un autre
on dirait que ils sont peut-être épuisés
de parler du sujet pensez je crois que
oui je crois que c'est vraiment
dix ans déjà premièrement je trouve que
10 ans c'est très long surtout avec le
réseau de la santé dans lequel
ça permet de la prévisibilité ça permet
une certaine stabilité une colère mais
je trouve qu'il y a trop d'inconnus qui
peuvent arriver pendant ces 10 ans là on
le sait à quel point les soins de santé
explosent d'année en année on sait à
quel point on est maintenant avec une
réalité de pandémie qui arrive on sait à
quel point les réseaux dans toutes les
provinces sont vétustes les employés
sont à bout sincèrement je trouve que
donnez moins d'argent qu'on s'attendait
quand même et maintenant sur un plus
long terme je trouve c'est une drôle
d'annonce on dirait que je compare pas
trop encore
un sentiment d'urgence jusqu'à un
certain point parce que Diane
aujourd'hui on a senti du côté fédéral
un petit message aux province
c'est-à-dire ce serait peut-être bien
qu'on s'entende avant le prochain budget
question de débloquer les sommes
rapidement mais on se demande où est
l'urgence soudainement parce que ça fait
des années qu'on en parle et que ça ne
bouge pas et là faudrait que c'est cool
quelques semaines entre l'offre et
l'acceptation pourquoi on pousse autant
mais il y a beaucoup de choses peut pas
changer moi j'entends un discours très
lucide ce que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup de lucidité par rapport
au fait qu'on était arrivé face à un mur
par rapport au fait que l'argent règlera
pas tout et du côté des provinces soyons
honnêtes ils ont avantage à signer
rapidement parce qu'on s'aventure
probablement vers un changement de
gouvernement donc ils sont pas fous les
premiers ministres provinciaux ils
voient bien survenir alors pourquoi
maintenant peut-être maintenant parce
que c'était une situation qui
s'accumulait là il y a le vieillissement
de la population il y a la post covid il
y a les ressources qui quittent
massivement le système public pour aller
dans le système privé donc c'est pas
subi c'est juste l'aboutissement de
plusieurs années de d'insouciance de
manque de lucidité et aussi est-ce qu'on
est arrivé à la fin de du budget en
quelque sorte qu'on a dans nos poches
est-ce que le gouvernement Trudeau qui a
dépensé énormément au cours des
dernières années se dit que tu en as
juste plus d'argent les premiers
ministres des provinces sont quand même
finalement ça sert à rien de gueuler il
y a juste plus d'argent dans les coffres
bon ça fait quelques fois que vous
mentionnez tous les deux l'argent ne
règlera pas tout dans la santé bon si
c'est pas juste une question d'argent
c'est une question de quoi Diane
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer parce que
on fait la même chose depuis des années
on a des défis on ajoute des enveloppes
on essaie de corriger le problème avec
plus d'argent si ça n'améliore pas le
système qu'est-ce qui va l'améliorer ben
je vous donnerai deux exemples d'abord
il y a une question de gouvernance il y
a une question de gouvernance
participative je vous donne deux
exemples à Charlevoix le Living Lab de
Charlevoix qui est un organisme
prototypage qui s'occupe des hôpitaux de
B St-Paul et de Charlevoix et là on
travaille en équipe on travaille en
équipe pour innover on travaille avec la
population avec les citoyens avec les
usagers et ça fonctionne c'est une
fonction c'est une mesure qu'on peut pas
développée à Montréal parce que c'est un
milieu rural mais l'idée de la
gouvernance et je vous donne un autre
exemple tout ce qui est rapport avec les
ressources infirmières le 9 mai 2022 il
y a eu des gros états généraux à
Montréal sur l'innovation infirmière
donc de ce côté-là il y a beaucoup de
sous-utilisation de beaucoup de gens
très compétents dans le réseau il y a un
décloisonnement de l'innovation à faire
et de la gouvernance aller chercher
l'impôt des usagers des patients il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire qui vont
au-delà de juste mettre de l'argent dans
le système donc Diane vous nous proposez
des choses à faire dans le système dans
le réseau existant Nicolas est-ce que ça
c'est suffisant ou est-ce qu'on doit
ouvrir la porte ou privée comme l'ont
suggéré certains
juste pour compléter Diane là on est en
train de remplir un seau qui est un seau
d'eau qui est trouvé donc peu importe
l'argent qu'on met ça va juste faire
flotter la patente mais ça va pas
l'améliorer il faut qu'on arrête de
jouer à l'autruche le privé existe déjà
là on fait quoi semblant qu'il existe
pas mais si on pouvait avec des balises
extrêmement bien précises comme la
France la Corée du Sud le Danemark
l'Australie pas des dictatures il y a
personne qui meurt aux portes des
hôpitaux là faire coexister le privé et
le public c'est une des solutions ça
n'est pas la seule elle a entièrement
raison quand elle dit que les
infirmières pourraient en faire plus pas
comprendre les moyens pas travailler 17
heures de plus mais elle pourrait
contribuer davantage avec leur savoir
les pharmaciens les physiothérapies tout
le réseau de la santé là et c'est pas
normal que ça prenne un billet d'un
médecin de famille pour aller faire une
radiographie juste pour dire
radiographie du du coude c'est tellement
complexe aujourd'hui le réseau que bien
entendu ben ça avance pas j'aimerais ça
commenter sur le privé moi oui allez moi
je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée il
y a un peu d'hypocrisie de la part du
gouvernement parce que d'un côté on veut
financer le privé de l'autre côté on
s'est fort bien qu'il y a plusieurs
ressources qui se développent en Sofia
ou bénévolat donc il y a beaucoup de
d'infirmière qui font du bénévolat dans
des ressources parallèles comme le
beaucumanitaire comme le spot et le
gouvernement le sait et le réseau de la
santé envoie des patients dans ces
réseaux là donc à quelque part comment
on peut d'un côté dire on va compter sur
le privé mais en même temps on souhaite
que des initiatives où il y a plein de
bénévoles qui s'occupe de tout ce qui
tombe dans les trous du système donc moi
j'ai un malaise avec ça je trouve que
quelqu'un mix marketing en quelque sorte
ou il faut un peu de tout pour que le
réseau fonctionne qu'on mise que sur le
public on voit qu'il y a des il y a des
pour il y a des comptes qu'on mise que
sur le privé il y a des pour et il y a
des comptes pourquoi on on ferait pas
comme les pays que j'ai nommé là ça va
extrêmement bien en quelque sorte dans
ces pays-là pour le réseau de la santé
il y a personne qui est pas
d'exagération comment ici on nous fait
peur là que le monde vont mourir
fondamentale de l'universalité du
système de santé
on a plus les moyens
parce que là ce qu'on propose c'est sur
10 ans mais si on voulait on voit
au-delà de ça le vieillissement de la
population va s'accélérer le fardeau de
la santé sur les finances publiques va
s'alourdir est-ce que c'est encore
fiable est-ce qu'on pousse la réflexion
jusque là on a plus les moyens on n'a
pas d'argent on n'a pas de nouvelle
entrée d'argent puis la semaine dernière
je voulais qu'on développe l'énergie
verte et
tout d'un coup on veut plus donc était
un moment donné comment on va faire de
l'argent pour financer tout ça c'est
quelque chose est gratuit ça perd de sa
valeur non je suis pas mais oui
il y a une valeur mais quand on parle de
l'argent qu'on a pas il y a un mot qu'on
faudrait qu'on commence à prononcer ses
prévention le coût des gens qui arrivent
dans le deuxième et le troisième âge
dépend de l'état dans lequel il y arrive
l'état physique et mental va déterminer
combien ça va coûter s'en occuper donc
si on sait qu'on a une société
vieillissante il serait temps qu'on
pense en prévention il est peut-être
même un peu tard pour ça d'ailleurs mais
bon la réflexion est en cours ça c'est
clair réflexion d'ailleurs de la part
des premiers ministres provinciaux qui
vont décider sous peu s'ils acceptent ou
non cette proposition fédérale monsieur
dame c'est un plaisir on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine bonne soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI